In the previous video, we
used linear optimization
to allocate ads.
In this video, we're going
to use a greedy approach
to allocate ads to queries.
The approach is called greedy
because we allocate the ads
sequentially and
we prioritize which
combinations of ad
and query to use,
based on the average
price per display.
So here we have a
spreadsheet set up
in the same way as the one
from the previous video
with some minor tweaks.
If we scroll down, we
have this table here,
which has cells corresponding
to combinations of advertisers
and queries, which tells us
basically how many times we
display a particular
advertiser's
ad with a particular query.
But to the side here,
we have another table
which we will use to
keep track at every stage
of our allocation process,
how much we can allocate--
how many displays we can
perform of a particular ad
with a particular query,
based on the budget,
and based on how many
displays of each query
remain unallocated.
Further down, where we
have our constraints,
we've added some new
cells here, which
are labeled with the
word "Remaining,"
to indicate how much of the
budgets of each advertiser
remaining, and how many
displays of each query
remain unallocated.
So let's get started with
our greedy allocation.
So to start, we go up to our
Average Price Per Display
table, and we find
the combination
of advertiser and
query which gives us
the largest average
price per display.
So, in this case, the largest
average price per display
is five.
And this happens when we display
Verizon's ad with Query 3.
So this is the first
variable that we're
going to change in
our greedy allocation.
These are the first,
basically the first displays
that we're going to use.
So if we scroll down, we
add Verizon in Query 3.
And to figure out
the budget limit,
we go to Verizon's remaining
budget which is $160.
And so we take that
$160, and we divide it
through by the average
price per display of $5.
So, we get this number
32, and so what this means
is that we can display
Verizon's ad with Query 3,
32 times based solely on the
remaining budget of Verizon.
Now, of course, we also have
to respect how many displays
are unallocated of each
query, and for query 3,
we have 80 displays.
So the query limit
at this stage is 80.
So now how many
times do we actually
display Verizon's
ad with Query 3?
Well, the most that we can
display Verizon's ad with Query
3 is going to be the smaller
of these two numbers.
And so in this case the smaller
of the two numbers is 32.
So, we allocate Verizon's
ad to Query 3, 32 times.
So now after we've changed
the value of this variable,
you can see that the budget
of Verizon has changed.
So now it is 0.
So we've completely
extinguished Verizon's budget,
and the remaining unallocated
displays for Query 3
has also changed.
So this number used to
be 80 and now it is 48.
So, since we've extinguished
Verizon's budget,
we go back up to our Average
Price Per Display table.
And so now we have to
select a new combination
to use in our allocation.
Since we've used up
Verizon's budget,
we're going to highlight these
cells corresponding to Verizon.
We're going to
highlight them in red
to indicate that we can't
use any of those combinations
anymore.
And from the remaining
cells in the table,
we want to find the combination
of Advertiser and Query
that gives us the largest
average price per display.
So in this case,
the next highest
is for T-Mobile and
Query 3, and in this case
the average price
per display is two.
So this is the next
combination that we'll
use in our allocation.
So if we scroll down, we
add T-Mobile and Query 3.
So now we have to
calculate the budget limit.
T-Mobile's remaining
budget is $100.
We take $100, and we divide
it through by $2 per display,
and we get this value of 50.
And the query limit for
T-Mobile and query 3
is the remaining number
of displays for Query 3,
which is 48.
So we scroll up and we add 48.
And so now, how many
times do we actually
display T-Mobile's
ad with Query 3?
Well, that number
is 48, because 48
is the smaller of
the two numbers.
So we go ahead and we add that.
And so now T-Mobile's
budget has changed.
So it's dropped
from 100 to four,
and the remaining
displays of Query 3,
that number has dropped to 0.
So there are no more
displays of Query 3
remaining that we can use.
So now we move on to the
next stage of our allocation,
and we go back to the Average
Price Per Display table.
And since we've used up all
of the displays of Query 3,
we're going to highlight the
remaining cells corresponding
to Query 3 in red,
just to remind us
that we can't use them.
And so now from the
remaining cells,
again, we want to find
the highest average price
per display combination.
And so from the remaining
cells, the highest average price
per display occurs when we use
T-Mobile's ad with Query 1.
So that's the next variable that
we'll use in our allocation.
So we scroll back down and
we add T-Mobile with Query 1.
To compute the budget limit,
we take T-Mobile's remaining
budget which is four,
$4, and we divide it
through by the average
price per display of $1.
So, we get four displays
according to the budget.
And the query
limit, in this case,
is 140, because there are
140 displays of Query 1
that haven't been
used towards any ad.
Now how many times
do we actually
display T-Mobile's with Query 1?
Again, we just take the minimum
of these two quantities, which
is four.
We go ahead and we enter
that into our table.
So now if you look
at the budgets,
we've completely extinguished
T-Mobile's budget
and the remaining number
of displays of Query 1
that haven't been allocated
has dropped to 136.
So now we move on to the
next stage of our allocation.
Again, we've eliminated
T-Mobile's budget.
So now we highlight
those cells in red.
And so now, we want to pick
the highest average price
per display from
the remaining cells.
Now in this case, the only two
combinations that remain to us
are to display AT&T's
ad with Query 1
and to display AT&T's
ad with Query 2.
Both of these have the same
average price per display,
so it doesn't matter which
one we really choose.
But for the purpose
of this solution,
let's just go with AT&T
displayed with Query 1.
So the average price
per display is 0.5.
So we go down, we add that
entry to our side table here.
And to compute the
budget limit, we
take AT&T's remaining
budget of 170,
and we divide it through by 0.5.
To get the query
limit, we just look
at the number of remaining
displays of Query 1,
which is 136.
So we add that.
And so now, obviously, the
smaller of the two quantities
is 136.
So we'll display AT&T's ad
with Query 1, 136 times.
So now if we look at the
state of our allocation,
we've basically used up all
the displays of Query 1.
And we've used up some
part of AT&T's budget,
though there's still a lot left.
So now we go back up
and we now proceed
to make the next allocation
in our greedy solution.
We've eliminated
AT&T in Query 1.
So now the only combination that
remains is AT&T with Query 2.
So we go down.
We add that entry
to our side table.
And so now to get
the budget limit,
we take AT&T's remaining
budget of $102,
and we divide it
through by 0.5, which
is the average price
per display to get 204.
And the query limit
now is 80, because 80
is the number of remaining
unassigned displays of Query 2.
And now the smaller of
the two numbers is 80.
And so we add 80 to our table.
And so at this point, we've
gone through all the entries
in our average price
per display table,
and we've eliminated
basically all of them.
And in terms of
the allocation, we
know that we can't make any more
allocations, because if we look
at our constraints, basically,
there are no more displays
of any query that have not been
assigned to any advertiser.
So all of these
entries here are 0.
And in this case, AT&T's budget
is still some positive value.
So we still have $62 of
ATamp;T's budget remaining.
But since we don't have any
more displays of any query
that we can use, we
are basically done.
So this is our greedy solution.
And so there are a couple
of interesting things
to note about this
greedy solution.
So the first is that the
actual combinations that
are used by the
greedy solution are
different from
those that are made
by the linear optimization
based solution.
So for example, in the
optimization solution,
if you recall, we only
used Query 3 with AT&T.
So we only displayed-- whenever
we displayed an ad with Query
3, it was only ATamp;T's ad.
But in this case,
we don't actually
display AT&T's ad
with Query 3 ever.
And in fact, we display only
T-Mobile's ad and Verizon's ad
with Query 3.
We don't use AT&T. So that's--
so the actual allocation
changes and so as a result,
the revenue that we get from
the greedy solution is different
from the revenue that we get
from the optimization solution.
If you recall, the revenue
from the optimization solution
was $428.
Now, this may not seem like
a very large difference.
So this is a difference of $60.
But in relative terms, this is
actually a rather large amount,
368 relative to 428
is roughly 14 percent.
And so, hopefully this
illustrates the fact
that an optimization
based solution
can provide a significant
difference in performance
relative to a basic
common sense solution.
So this concludes our
construction and our discussion
of the greedy solution.
In the next video, we will go
back to our linear optimization
model, and we will consider
some of the sensitivity analysis
that goes along with that model.